I love your backdrop, Maddie, I'm feeling that.
Gotta have some fun, we're playing with toys, right?
(audience laughs)
Well, and that is why I recruited my dear friend,
friend of the show, it's Leo Kelly,
AKA The Shirley Temple King!
(audience cheers and applauds)
Hey!
Hi Drew, how are you?
I am great, how are you?
I mean, amazing.
(audience laughs)
What's better than a platter of toys?
There is nothing better than a platter of toys.
All right, Maddie, what is first?
Show us everything.
Yeah, let's just jump right in.
So if you need a hand, I know something that'll help.
This is the Mega Cyborb Hand, and this is so cool.
But what's even cooler is that kids will build
this working mechanical hand with more than 200 pieces
all while they're learning about the science
of robotics and hydraulics.
So this is really great for kids who are into robots,
or kids who love building and wanna try something new.
Yeah, look at that, it has this really great action
with articulated fingers so you can move each one
one by one, so you can also grip and lift objects.
(audience cheers and applauds)
I got it!
Oh, you, oh!
Grip it, Drew, grip it!
All right!
You did it!
(audience cheers and claps)
Whoo, there you go!
I love the way this toy is made.
I can definitely agree.
This is a great toy for kids that like, you know,
STEM toys, and things that you get to build.
'Cause this is, you get to build it, thumbs up!
(audience laughing)
This is a thumbs up from me.
All right, I'm so into the first one.
Okay, what's next, Maddie?
Yeah, we're starting off strong.
All right, so have you ever wondered what would happen
if you mixed foosball with basketball?
Well, this is the Foosketball game,
and it is an epic mashup.
And now you can bring this new sporting event
right to your home.
So first, you release all of the mini basketballs,
and then you move your figure around to capture one,
and then you use your hand to try to score baskets.
I made it in!
(audience cheers and claps)
You did, Leo!
Drew!
Leo!
You did it!
Leo got a basket!
(audience applauding)
By the way, you know, who really liked this game also?
My cats.
(audience laughs)
I'm not kidding, like, all these little orange balls
were like flying around my house,
and I was like, what is going on?
The cats went bananas over this game.
Okay, Leo, what do you think of this game?
Yay, nay?
Yay for me.
Great, okay, good.
Maddie, what do you got next?
All right, so in a world of endless virtual calls
and video chats, you're on mute has got to be
the most repetitive phrase of the year.
So now this phrase is an actual game.
So, in "You're On Mute" players will take turns
going behind this screen that will zoom in on your mouth.
(audience laughs)
So there are three rounds.
In "Strong Connection," you are going to talk
just like I am right now.
(audience laughs)
In "Weak Connection," you just only use one word clues.
And when "You're On Mute," you can only mouth the words.
I love how much fun you guys are having.
Hi Drew.
All right, so.
Okay,
you are so cute in that box.
Thank you.
I'm not kidding.
Yeah, so why don't we try a round?
So, I'm gonna say a word,
and you're gonna guess what I'm saying, okay?
Okay, I'm not great at reading lips in general, so.
Okay, got it.
Okay, you go.
Yeah, Leo, put your screen up, and then, yeah,
Drew, guess what he's saying.
Beach ball?
(audience cheers and claps)
Leo!
Didn't even follow up for Drew, very baller!
Thank you, Leo, it's 'cause we're a good team.
By the way, I can't believe how quick on the draw
they were with this.
Like, they already have a game called "You're On Mute,"
it's brilliant, like, they acted fast!
It's crazy.
Leo, why don't you come around the front,
and Maddie, why don't you explain what we have next?
Yeah, so I don't know if kids or parents are going
to be more excited with this one.
This is a Foamo, and it is the toy of the summer.
It is a foam machine that will have everything
that you need to make mountains of foam in just minutes.
So you just add water, plug it in, and you're ready to go.
And parents everywhere are going to love
that the foam solution is hypoallergenic and biodegradable.
So you're not gonna have a big mess in the backyard.
I do know that Leo is excited about this
and I actually had to hide this from my toy friend because-
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh my gosh!
Whoo!
This is so cool!
Drew, put that down and come around here!
(audience laughs)
All right, you're right,
I know, I'm like an old grandma in the back.
Who cares?
I know, you're right, Leo, I'm better than that.
Whoo!
Oh my gosh, okay, ready?
(Leo singing)
This is the best toy out of them all!
This is top five Leo's favorite toys,
it's probably gonna be Drew's top five too.
I just wanna know, are we in agreement
that the number one toy out of all of these is?
Foamo.
Foamo, agreed.
Hands down.
Hands down, this is obviously-
Wait, wait-
Also my-
Hands, hands down!
Hands down!
Drop the hand!
(audience laughing)
I think the Foamo is gonna be so embraced.
Just chill out with Foamo for the rest of the summer.
And guess what you don't have to have?
What?
FOMO.
(audience laughs)
No fear of missing out here!
Okay, and guess what?
Thanks to Toy Insider, we're giving each one of these toys
all to our VFFs.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Whoo!
I really appreciate these wonderful things in life.
I don't know if it's that it's the little things,
or we just wanna see each other happy.
I think this is just the ultimate example of sparking joy.
This is just a big bath.
(audience laughs)
All right, thank you, Maddie Michalik,
and Leo Kelly, my dear.
Go to thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
for more information on these toys.
(warm rock music)
♪ Oh, oh ♪